okay yeah welcome back from the lunch
break Lorenzo rakia is going to talk
again about the continuous methods and
as I know for sure he has plenty of
experience educating ignorant office
mates Thank You Thomas Anna stop asking
if there are any questions that came up
over lunch about any of the material you
saw so far
now on we are gonna meander a bit more
and I just wanted to make sure
comfortable so remember the last thing
we remanded to essentially go through
the analysis of what I call the primal
averaging which an example is this frank
world
method I wanted to clarify that what the
result to actually showed is more
general than frank world
it applies to any case in which you have
this smooth property on your gradient
map and your non smooth property on the
mirror map so it's more general than the
Frank wolf and the next thing I wanted
to do was to move before we move on to
move on to the kind of the next case
which is non smooth gradient and a
smooth mirror map I wanted to give you a
bit more of kind of a pictorial
intuition of what this means in practice
for gradient methods so you should you
should really think of primal averaging
and Frank wolf as a proxy for a blasian
descent sorry the one method that
haven't really talked about in this talk
is kind of unconstrained gradient
descent but you just walk towards the
gradient and the reason I haven't talked
about it it's because it's kind of
special it's hard to present it in this
framework that you can because there is
no real set it's not easy to define what
are the points you're taking a complex
combination of because you're
unconstrained so
matter of fact the way you to think
about unconstrained vision descent is
that you in some sense you are
constructing a very large ball around
your points and you're thick you're
picking points on the boundary of this
very large pole the ball that is
guaranteed to include your optimum and
those are the points that you have
taking a complex combination of but even
then there are a couple of details in
that construction that make it messy and
that's why I decided to present Frank
wolf instead for which we have a much
nicer understanding but a lot of what
the intuition that I'm going to say
about primal i've arranging and frank
wolf will also apply to one constrain
gradient descent and the point i want to
make is essentially this that we saw the
the way Frank were for mahjongg primal
averaging works is that the it's
focusing on the function it's really
looking at the function value at X bar
so the function value of the current
primal point and that is the part of the
problem that's smooth and that's the
part of the problem where the algorithm
really moves in the direction of the
gradient and tries to make progress and
that's borne out in practice because
what happens when you do get in descent
is that you're going to query a point
get the gradient and together with your
gradient you know you wanna you're gonna
see you in a query point you're going to
move to a point decreases the functional
value you're gonna get the gradient that
gives you a lower bound but what happens
when you do so should respect those
rights are what that means when you look
at the descent in practice is that
within descent
really wants to decrease the function
value but it's not caring too much about
the lower bound because on the lower
bound side like as we saw it's really
just maintaining this average of lower
bounds so in practice what happens is
that this lower bound
increases very slowly
and these two issues are related because
gradient descent in some sense is
focusing a lot on on decreasing the
function value and not as much as
increasing the lower bound in the case
when your mirror map is also smooth you
can do better so in the case say you
just have both your function on your
mirror mapper smooth then there is a
better thing you can do which is what I
call a dual averaging update and the
reason is if you want to reduce the
duality gap now you could take another
gradient staff here that decreases the
function value but in Twitter is
something you can do to decrease to
improve your lower bound is take a
longer step which might overshoot the
optimum but if you overshoot you get the
gradient at points in the opposite
direction and that's very nice for the
lower bound because now suppose I take a
convex combination of this gradient and
this gradient then I get this gradient
and it is a very nice lower bound yeah
so in general in practice depending the
implementation issues here but they're
like theoretically phase like a
implementation of these algorithms that
faithful to the theoretical algorithm I
will display will have will show you
that the dual averaging updates in
general tend to overshoot the gradient
descent but the gradient descent tries
to make smaller steps because he doesn't
want to increase the function value now
if you remember this
picture I showed you long the very
beginning of this talk I wanted
that's exactly what's happening in this
picture the dis gradient descent is just
trying to decrease the function value
this guy it's okay we were shooting
because when it overshoots is getting a
gradient that you can use to improve the
dual solution a lot in some sense I hope
this gets some intuition about this
momentum methods like why would you want
to keep going why would you want to
overshoot and the reason is that by
overshooting you are making dual
progress so this is kind of bit of
intuition which I find useful
okay so let's get back to the kind of
the next method we want to look at it
yes it's really very similar to what you
just saw is I'd say that things are
happening in the dual now so this is a
method where your F is non smooth but
your sigh is strongly concave or you can
think about - I strongly convex
and then what this tells you is that
this forward knife is not smooth that is
backward map is move now
and in this is a case where this may not
be a gradient in this may be a sub
gradient now because this function being
the smooth in principle it might not be
differentiable and sometimes there is a
way of I'm gonna not going to talk about
today but feel free to ask me offline in
which this can be related to proximal
operators and I'm not going to go into
it today so I mentioned the properties
so an example of this is maybe you
common problem you may want to do in a
statistical testing is you want to do
Entergy maximization under some linear
constraints so then your linear
constraint C would be encoded in this
non smooth part and then entropy is a
strongly concave function with respect
to the l1 norm it would fit exactly this
kind of thing
so and again what's gonna happen here is
very similar to what we saw before the
only smooth component in this picture is
this mirror map so the only place in
which I'm going to use my current dual
solution is the bar is in the definition
of the lower bound everything I'll see
on my upper bound and my other lower
bound turn everything is an average
what and this is Luther bomb okay and
I'm not gonna go much into detail
because if you think about it everything
I suffer Primal averaging applies
exactly to this case this is exactly the
same privilege anywhere I flipped primal
in do it exactly the same picture so
what's happening is that instead of
having remember that for primal avenging
I would evaluate the gradient of F at X
bar and map it to CT yeah if things are
flipped
so what's happening is that I am taking
my current dual solution using the
mirror map to map it to a primal point
and this I'm disregarding my current
primal solution am i looking at kind of
my instantaneous primal solution and I'm
mapping it back to to the draw space
really think of it as vision descent in
the dual space which is why it's called
the mirror design
and I'm gonna go into one example
specific example of this later on here I
just wanted to emphasize the symmetry
and so because this is the same as the
primal I'm gonna move on and I'm gonna
get to a more interesting case which is
the case in which we can achieve
acceleration we can get faster algorithm
and that the picture is that this map is
most and now this map is also smooth
so you can
[Music]
imagine what I'm gonna say is that so
now again up in the upper bound I know a
few smooth so that's the contribution of
f9 in the rubber bound I know ops I the
psystar is moved so that's the
contribution of Tristar everything else
is an average
and right
actually I see I I don't I didn't have
the derivation here I wanna show the
derivation just to show it once more so
I claim that given this definition of a
boundary were bound if I decide if I
enforce my invariant I'm gonna get to
this kind of dynamic so let me show you
let me tell you first what was the
dynamic and then we can do the
calculation on the whiteboard so the
dynamic is really what you would expect
in the sense that because now both the
gradient of F and the veins of psystar
smooth you can apply both of them at
this current solution okay so now both
both X bar and z bar are involved in the
dynamic and that is what's behind
acceleration if you want to think about
if you want to develop some intuition I
recommend trying to think about zero-sum
games in which ax is the primal player
and Z is in the dual player and it's an
interesting exercise to try to think
about kind of what kind of strategies
these different dynamics correspond to
because I wanted to do the formulation
so when I differentiate so now I'm gonna
show that I invested in the Amish life
I'm going to show that this is actually
the dynamic that we get from the gap in
variant so when I differentiate my god
now I have two kinds of terms I have the
terms that come from the smooth part and
the terms that come from the non smooth
part
right right it's the case in which both
are smooth but remember that F star and
Sai are still known smooth those are
because there are four terms there is f
sy f star and side star so in this case
two of them are smooth and two we're not
smooth it's such a good question when
when everything is smooth then you can
recover this linearly convergent target
so when the convergence is like a log 1
over epsilon let me do this calculation
on the board okay so first I so this is
the derivative of my upper bound sorry
this is the derivative of my gap and it
has these two terms X bar dot and V Bar
dot and so the way you go about
eliminating those terms is that you use
the fact that your X bar and your Z bar
are averages so you get a simple
expression because
averages
and you're gonna get alpha prime and
these alpha T plus one cancels with this
you just get the gradient at X bar T
that's the first stroke you get
something similar on the second row
writing on the board
let's just let me skip all these three
indices because they're very nice on the
PowerPoint but when you write everything
is a time T in any case so then you get
shy of Z bar plus the gradient
psystar Z bar minus y bar and then this
a last two terms are just averages are
just function values they are as star of
Z minus besides that my side effects
okay so we want this big expression to
be zero
the idea is again that we try to make it
zero we try to define things trying to
define our Z in our acts to form a
conjugate pairs such that things cancel
out so let's see what what we can do in
this setting so notice I have f of X bar
here and I have a start of Z here so it
makes sense to make Z and X bar be a
conjugate pair some F at T plus 1
canceled out when I replaced the Z bar
and the X bar because of this that's
convenient because now I just have this
alpha prime candle in front of
everything
and but so the first thing I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna define Z to be Delta f of X
bar so that's gonna take care it's gonna
make Z and X bar a conjugate pair and it
means that this Plus this is gonna imply
that F of X bar plus F star of Z equals
Z X bar
and it's convenient because I actually
add ZX Bob appears in my formula because
this guy here is Z and this is X bar so
what happens when I when I when I make
this assignment by virtue of this
assignment I get rid of this term this
term and then the X bar
now I do exactly the same thing on on
the dual side I have side start OC bad
side effects so I make actions about a
conjugate pair
and is that the same reasoning means
that I can get rid of guy this guy and
this guy what I'm left with at the end I
did things right should just be alpha
prime of T reacts
- here and then - in the X distances
everything is 0 I just want it to do
this because in this is what all this
proofs in the end boil boil down to you
have some derivative of your gap and you
want to choose your disease and your
axis to form these conjugate pairs to
make things zero so any questions about
this derivation we're gonna do a a
similar one for a more interesting case
soon so I wanted to have this one down
now it's time to go underworld
okay
all right so we have the dynamic I want
to talk a bit about the discretization
of flexibility dynamic expectation for
acceleration is actually completely is
actually more complex so I'm not going
to go into the full detail but that an
example of very interesting ideas I want
to I want to sketch so the first point
is that forward Euler this nice simple
scheme I've shown you four primary
averaging so for Valera doesn't work you
just do for Verdi that you get this only
gives you a bound that looks like L d
squared over T which is the same as 4 PI
by bridge so forward Euler doesn't does
not like to improve the convergence and
how do you overcome this and what's nice
about the Federation is that there are
two ways to use discretization to
overcome this problem
so there is one approach by I like to
call an Asterix trick
which gives raise to what we pro call
accelerating a gradient descent master
of trick is the following you do forward
Euler
so what happens when you do forever
either you are at some point see
actually you can work in configuration
space so when I write the point is not
only a primal point is both it's a
primal and ended well point you do for I
do forward Euler and I get to my new
point and unfortunately I still have a
bunch still have too much discretization
error and then Nesterov has this idea
that the actual gradient of F is
pointing in a different direction
and because f is moved I know that I can
take a little step in the direction and
improve my functional value so what
Nesterov does is says I'm not just gonna
move to this point I'm also gonna take a
little gradient step come to this point
Y Z bar the dual part is left the same
and now the next thing this says it uses
convexity to argue that if I now take a
combination of these two points the
combination that is closer to this side
the gain I make from this goodness that
exactly matches the discretization error
and so I can I can obtain a I can
actually match the kind of gap that we
saw before for just a continuous method
which was G 0 over T squared so that's I
just want to give you a kind of
pictorial idea of what it does the
calculation is not too hard so the idea
the point the point about this is that
it's kind of I mean I don't have a good
systematic interpretation of what this
is it's a good a doc trick for when you
have smoothness the smoothnes guarantees
that because the gradient is changing
slowly you can always make a little step
let improve your function so this is
what's called nested of what I think of
as Nestor trick then there is a more
there is a more kind of slightly more
systematic approach ok if I call this
Nestor of trick I have to call this
nemirovsky strictly this is not a trick
it's smaller it's more and so here the
idea is that
it's the following so we have an
integral you know like I said we are
trying to discretize this the integral
of the gap between t and t plus 1 this
green function here is d dt alpha t plus
1 GT so that's my invariant
time to discretize this guy and for a
dollar just takes this uses this
approximation and one way to think about
what nemirovsky does is that it's
something more similar to what people
call the midpoint rule in numerical
integration so the way it works is that
you are again at X bar z bar
let me turn off the money yeah but I
don't know I like to be narrative I feel
emotional about
okay so Ramirez who's idea is this and I
have X bar z bar I'm gonna take a
smaller Oliver dialer stack what step
length is half of what he should be I
get to this exact I got to a point x SZ
hat now I use this point to estimate the
gradient of of my function so I take
this gradient here so that the gradient
of my dynamics at this point and I
applied at my original point
and this here's this this is my next
point
it's an extrapolation step so I'm just
because the idea is that I really would
like to estimate what the gradient looks
like in the middle of this interval at T
plus 1/2 I would like to take this guy
and then used and then use maybe this
approximation for the integral and so
how can I access this point and it would
kind of simulate what devolution would
look like for for a half a step plank
and then I use this point and the
gradient and the relative of my dynamic
has at this point as as a proxy for this
so that's and that achieves also you
know it again
you get the same bound wait
it's do anything no because it never
asked his trades they're supposed to be
same as mere aprox
wait for the actual standard bear
products this family there's not a 1/2
right you just think you're actually a
4-step so that differently so that yeah
yeah you're right so
I'm sorry cheating good variations of
this you can do this step line can be
different but I mean in principle you
can think about his intuition there is
also a different intuition of what this
method does which comes from something
called backward Euler do people know
what backward Euler is the idea is this
so in one line backward order which kind
would be the way of a proximity integral
where instead of taking this line or
this line you take the gradient at the
endpoint of your interval this seems
easy enough but there is a catch which
is you are doing an evolution right so
you are at X bar z bar and you're
following some dynamic so the
differential of this is some function
let's call it time evolution and so what
you're trying to when you do forward
order you just your step follows the
time evolution at X bar z bar so this is
for bar doctor and in the backward Euler
you have a more complicated task what
you want to find is you want to find a
point X bar prime z bar prime such that
the gradient at this point this is the
time of Ellucian at X bar prime z bar
prime when you apply it in a negative
direction takes you back to X bar z bar
so yeah when you do fertilizer you take
the gradient at your current point when
you do backward Euler you want this is
also called implicit it's an implicit
method because there is no you need to
find this point X prime Z prime which
has this property the property that the
gradient of the time evolution at that
point takes you back to the original
point
I don't know
yeah probably not they shouldn't be
okay so this is the idea so and what's
an easy matter is explicit
so implicit methods if I was able to do
exact backward Euler I would actually
have no discretization error because but
it turns out that this task inside
backward order is have to compute it's
it's hard to do to find the point you
know because you don't know what the the
gradient at that point will be so what
Namir ask is trying to do is in some
sense is you can think of it as trying
to approximate this backward euler step
and this can be made more formal turns
out that there is a natural iterative
way to approximate backward Euler and
this step that Namir ask is doing is the
first step in this iterative way to
approximate banqueted ready went too
much into the detail so here I wanted to
mention a number of a kind of I think
conceptual questions that I find
interesting first it's not really clear
if this to me at least whether this is a
better idea than this one both in
practice and in theory there are a bunch
of open questions about what happens
when these gradients you get the
gradient of F is noisy and then the
choice of discretization may have an
impact in the way the noise effects you
so there is an interesting question
about if you have Gaussian noise on top
of your gradient articles which is
relevant for differential privacy it's
not clear if this method and this method
have the same performance
and then as we talk about open questions
and recent developments there is a lot
of work going on in trying to figure out
if there are different ways to
discretize in these dynamics that are
better for specific problems let me
mention one example
and very important election is trying to
understand what other notions of
smoothness you can use in your
discretization so we have for example a
result that applies to positive linear
programs these are linear programs where
they pack angle P so you want to
maximize 1 transpose X such that a of X
is less than 1 and what does it mean
it's the positive repeat it's because I
tell you that all the entries of this
matrix a are non-negative so now if I
used this method out of the box the best
I could do would be running time to get
to an epsilon approximation would be
something like
and this is essentially achieved by by
doing something called smoothing plus
this master of algorithm it's very
surprising that we can aspire to the
fact that this is non-negative to do a
different discretization and this
position gives you a running time which
is independent of the size of this is
the number of iterations the number of
iteration that's independent of the
numbers of the size of the entries of a
so this result is it doesn't work when a
when the matrix your constraint matrix
is general but somehow something in the
fact that this is non-negative together
with the choice of dynamics that we do
which is actually this is the same
choice of dynamic as this but we have a
differentiation that allows you to get a
much better behavior we understand what
this is beyond this problem but it shows
the table I think interesting avenues to
research that yes there are one because
there is no square right so these are 1
plus epsilon multiplicative
approximation
so it's a different notion of viral from
the additive approximation driven using
so far it's a 1 plus epsilon or
multiplicative estimation why should I
should not type check then yes if I if I
just double the whole matrix a if I have
there's scaling
your problem is very skilled right right
right today some conditions gaming
you're right yeah there's a condition
about the scaling of a is fixed I think
something like the mean and
infinity-norm of a column of a is 1 or
something like that there is some thick
scaly
but okay okay so let's think let's I
just wanted to give you a rough idea
interesting the Russians in digitization
also Jonah Sherman you know II just
talked now II yes the recent paper where
it has some very cool stuff different
kind of way of discretizing a different
conditions different notion of
smoothness in some sense that you can
use to get a better discretization out
of backward order so actually like the
site of research in terms of finding
this problem specific discretization so
this dynamic and one of you one might
ask why haven't people done this before
but
so these disposition schemes have been
known since either like the name
suggests and I think part my explanation
is that people in for the nudies people
in Converse optimization have been
interested in more general problem
classes so the problem kind of problem
classes they work with small strong
comebacks composite don't have enough
structure that you can really go and
play at this granular level by
discretization but once you get into the
TCS community we're interested in
solving problems that have a lot of
stretch like mass flow that is a graph
stretch there is no negativity you know
it could be a mattress touch there's all
kind of stuff where we can really
exploit that in the discretization so I
think it would be a great you know thing
to think about in the contests of a
program like this one what we are trying
to bridge continuous and discrete
[Music]
yeah the question was if I had not used
HD in this iterative solution of this LP
the the exponents this respondent would
have been squared this you can still
keep as it is there's a little trick
that I love the center of the matrix so
one to infinity
okay so in the last ten minutes let me
do something important which is talk
about non smooth optimization you know I
covered all these three cases in my
slide where one of each components was
smooth but a lot of the problems that we
are interested in especially in discrete
optimization relaxations which are non
smooth like this guy
nothing is most here so how do we deal
with this and the other is a great trick
that I mean a great technique that I
want to I want to show you
and I'll try to talk more about this
you know they will either workshop on
fast iterative methods and I think we
will hear more about this but let me
give you the basic idea so a lot of the
problems like as I said you just have
mean of F X f of X may be inside some
closed they come compact combat set
there is an oxide so far we worked we
have worked in this world where we have
this nice sigh is mirror map becomes in
the object but if my problem doesn't
have doesn't come website what am I
going to do so yeah the nice thing is
that you're going to build your own side
so in some sense you're gonna add X I
here
of course you want to build it such that
so what do you want of the spy or deep
sigh you want Delta sized star to be
computable and weak because you are at
it you probably also want it to be
smooth to be you want this stuff to be
smooth so you can actually use it
effectively so if you just do this then
you really change the optimization
problem a lot you're optimizing
something different but there is a trick
now that if you think about it our in
say our upper bound do this for the
lower bound as well is a function of
time in these methods so what I could do
is I could think of working in my I can
make my terms in my upper bound also
depend on time so my what would my upper
bound be I could use so because F is not
smooth I need to use the average sorry I
need to use average on my on the upper
bound 0 plus the integral
then undisturbed because understand
so okay so what's gonna happen is that
I'm gonna add the weight of one over
alpha T plus one on this term so I'm
gonna scale it down with time
remember this is my invariant
now my invariant is going to be in an
average
let me skip some oh did it let me just
like an average of the FS because the
acts are not smooth
maverick of yeah
and yeah this term is still gonna have
an alpha T plus one in it
this is my kind of this is the upper
bound and then the lower bound and I
look like
I start the mines so let me explain
can we turn on the screen again
can we turn on the projector again
so if you notice when we did this
business for composite optimization
whenever whenever had an average it was
not scaled in the expression for the gap
so see inside this black kitty this is
an expression this is part of the gap
and the average because I'm multiplied
by alpha a desire age is just that
what's happening now is that because I
introduced this scaling here the terms
the dependent on side are all divided
are all scaled down by our all-sky down
by alpha t
so what's happening is some science is
that at time T I'm optimizing kind of a
different time function at each time T
and the function of optimizing at time T
is this function the weight of my mirror
map depends on time as alpha becomes
large this becomes negligible so what
this allows me to do is now is choose
and I can introduce my own size and use
it in the algorithm as I will do in
composite optimization you can do the
same kind of calculation as it before to
figure out what the dynamic is the
dynamic is the same as we saw in dual
averaging except that there is an extra
scaling here it's easy to deal with and
what you get is is a way of functionally
what this does is really you are
creating a smoother version of F at each
time T so there is a way of interpreting
all of this as smoothing the function f
another way to think about this
transformation is what people call
figure this out recently people in
optimization called homotopy so the idea
behind the Mata P
is that you know at time T what for
indeed in the beginning your function is
just going to be F minus I so at time T
zero you're optimizing this function
then as time progresses your function
changes and F becomes more important
until you get to a function which is
essentially F and this kind of
continuous transformation from this
function here which maybe was an easy
function to this function here which is
a highly non smooth function is what
they call a Matta P and it's also can be
related to preconditioning the point is
if you have a non smooth function you
can introduce website that depends on
time and have this nice transition from
easy problem to a harbor and so lots of
these techniques that you might have
seen like multiplicative weight updates
for nanos muslim ization are doing this
might be to talk about that offline what
that means is that so the existence of
this attack this way of dealing with a
smooth optimization by building your own
side is very interesting because it
brings it brings a different weapon to
the game it brings the possibility you
know in you get you got to design your
own site and different size have
different properties so very nice or
sorry of research is what is the right
size also this is also called the
regularizer what is the right answer for
a given known as most problem and here I
have also lots of examples people want
to talk to me I'm thinking about
[Applause]
[Music]
the question was what's the curve how do
I think of multiple activate Saturdays
as an extension of this Amato command
and the idea is this that when you do
weight updates to say that you're
actually just doing it for online
learning so in the online learning
setting you have some cumulative this is
your cumulative loss vector this is the
sum of the losses you've seen so far the
way you define your weight update the
way you define your point is you look at
the argument you know you want to have a
point that does well against all the
losses you've seen so far plus some
regularizer and this could be the
entropy this will give you multiple
weight updates because if this is the
entropy and axis on the simplex the
solution the what you get from XT is e
to the minus LT over the sum of I
understand
so this is multi pretty way too late how
is this Omata P well it's a matter P
because you're really scaling by alpha T
so as T goes on this term which comes
from your function is increasing weight
and this term is fixed so actually if
you apply this a multi method for
another most function you get exactly
something like the key in these waiter
plates is that the contribution of your
regularizer is staying fixed through
iterations while the contribution of the
function is increasing
other questions
okay then things again and we'll Harmon
Oliver
[Applause]